this Hospital in the imfal East District
of Manipur is filling up with the
wounded they're the latest casualties of
ethnic violence between the cookie
tribal group and ethnic majority Mayte
people hijam noacha survived Tuesday's
violence his wife is relieved he's
getting intensive care
we are from the working class and I'm
not sure how he got injured I received a
notification about his injury and that's
when I rushed here to the hospital it's
really disheartening
bullet's ridden bodies have been taken
to a nearby morgue police say they're
the victims of a major gun battle in a
kooky tribal Village most were from the
Mayte community
tensions between the kugi and mate in
Manipur have been growing for years
the flash point is mainly over the
distribution of land jobs and education
it was sparked by a protest against the
state High Court's recommendation to
give tribal status to the mateys who
make up half of the state's population
since then homes and shops have been
burned down dozens of people have been
killed and tens of thousands forced from
their homes
at least 40 000 people have moved to
relief camps such as this one for their
safety but some complain of being
separated from their families and having
Bare Essentials
this is very painful our families our
daughters wives and mothers are living
in different camps we want to call them
but there are a lot of difficulties
have been sent to the state to search
for illegal weapons
back at the hospital medical teams are
doing what they can to treat the injured
as the number of dead continues to rise
rahila Muhammad Al Jazeera